to know what's the status of your Star
Trek Star Trek I don't know and honestly
I don't know yeah it's um it may or may
not happen it's not like I get updates
it's just I haven't heard anything for a
long time the last time I spoke about it
you know there were there were there
were no immediate plans I one thing I
did mention in when I spoke about it
recently is that for us losing Anton
Yelchin the way we did was a real blow
and I think it slightly took the wind
out of our sails in terms of our
enthusiasm to to do another one just
because we're now missing one of our
family you know it would be he would be
conspicuous by his absence you know and
I think in some respects that's we're
all still in contact you know we were
emailing with each other the other day
just saying checking in how are we and
stuff but it's not like any any of us
have been banging on the door a parent
saying hey when are we doing this you
know if they say we'd like to do another
movie I'm sure we'll all jump at the
chance so I I miss those guys you know
and I love making those films but I just
don't know you know Noah's Noah Hawley's
project was has been mentioned and maybe
that will happen I don't know anything
about that
so yeah I'm as in I'm as in the dark as
everyone else I mean I'm in the same
boat as you guys the thing that's
interesting about truck right now is you
have a lot of series they just announced
the pike series this morning for CBS all
access there's a lot going on on the
small screen and that leads to sort of I
guess what I'm wondering is for Star
Trek on the big screen I think there's
two ways you can either do the
big-budget mega action or has there been
ever any talk about doing I don't want
to say a micro-budget Star Trek movie
but a much lower budget Star Trek movie
that maybe allows for more size
I and stuff that is it a four-quadrant
movie so it's sort of like me act like
the hardcore Trek fans and not making it
at such a large budget yeah I think
that's that would be a good idea you
know of course you know Star Trek has
its has its appeal and those that appeal
can be converted into numbers which can
you know an account and configure out
and and the fact is the appeal of Star
Trek is slightly more niche than the
appeal of say the Marvel movies which
make huge amounts of money and and and
have this really really broad appeal and
they do very well I think Star Trek is a
little just a little bit more niche so
it isn't going to hit those kind of
numbers so yes the obvious thing to do
would be to create not go for that
massive spectacle go over something a
little bit more restrained in the vein
of the original series yes that would be
a brilliant thing to do and I'm sure it
probably has been discussed but who
knows I don't know it's one of those
it's one of those kind of frustrating
questions because I wish I had more to
say about it I totally agree with you I
think that would be something that you
you get it you specialize a little bit
more you know it's it's a weird one and
and maybe TV is a better place for it
now you know and now we're dealing with
a television has evolved so much it's
become something which is very much a
contemporary appear of cinema you know
it's simply viewed in a different way
and but the scope of it it isn't a
reduced scope anymore you can still do
masses of interesting things and it can
still look modern and not inexpensive
and maybe
television is a better there's a better
format for Star Trek that's where it
started you know yeah I I would love to
see a Star Trek 8 episode or 10 episode
series featuring all of you guys I mean
I would love it uh and I think that fans
would love it I know it's not going to
happen because I just doubt it but man
down yeah I'd love to work with those
guys again and you know obviously Star
Trek
it's very dear to me and
[Music]
you know so we'll see we'll see what the
future holds